my name is Paul this is lunch in
Antarctica everyday welcome to the
kitchen sits next to the science disc
I live on cheese toasties so we make
that's lunch
my puppy here three or four a day it's
got a bit of cheese here you can you can
either use this or you can just use this
stuff scattered all over the table so
then all you've got to do is find all
the ingredients which would twelve
people on site there can be anywhere
that's part of the mission so got to
find bread which is usually somewhere
around here all right who hit the breed
here's some more so then we have butter
bit of butter there so then when he
cheese and we also need salami which
might be in the fridge where's the
fridge fridge this outside it's quite
big come with me we'll go to the fridge
alright so this is the fridge so
somewhere in one of these chili bins it
does defrost it's not ideal
alright look at that success we're out
of the fridge too cold in the fridge
back into the team I found good stuff
yeah this is the good stuff
let's check the do a similar used by the
6th of June 2013 that was three years
ago salami
alright cheese relish this is good stuff
get that and a bit of that on that
covers all the food groups from the base
of the pyramid to the top that's all of
them that's the works grains it's paying
that in there now we wait
well you don't really use plates we use
bowls because we don't have to do dishes
so we eat breakfast lunch dinner with
the spoon and a bowl when you have to do
dishes because you can lick the spoon
that's clean paper towel bowl is clean
done just baby wipes paper towels and
spit that's a clean spoon got my
sandwiches just like you oh no one
that's a vegetarian one there there you
go that's good that's good that's gonna
be hot what's yeah release the goodness
first the heat there's a lot of anger in
there
that's hot Oh
no I said
first cook never gets old that's always
good it's the only reward after a day of
work this was all you dream of when
you're in the field